okay everybody a twist on this season of
the Chad Lirette yes the Bachelorette is
still all about chat night two of the
Chad Stravaganza saw Chad on a
two-on-one date with one of his many
arch nemesis Alex we don't actually know
much about Alex except that he's a
Marine and he wants Chad sent home
Alex dish to Jojo about Jim he literally
was telling Jordan like he's gonna find
him after the show and he'll beat his
ass
Jojo promptly eliminated Chad I don't
want somebody that threatens other
people I'm gonna say goodbye to you here
now I'll be honest as much as I love
this show I was bored at this point was
this really the big ending we were gonna
get after committing to two straight
nights of The Bachelorette
and what will the show be without Chad
well the last two minutes did not
disappoint normally when someone is sent
home from a two-on-one they are not seen
again but
I'm just here
oh my god Chad will never be sent home I
can't stop watching this and next
episode looks sensational I would hate
for any of them to walk away from this
not knowing the truth
what is going on there one there's a
reason for you to be worried over the
Doraemon okay here's my prediction Chad
sticks around for a bit and Jojo tells
the other guys about Chad's mom passing
away so they'll be more empathetic and
then Chad locks himself in a bathroom
maybe I don't know anymore
what I do know is who's comforting Jojo
at the end here Jordyn definitely big
chemistry though Luke got some good air
time in this f2 which meant we got some
good abs time and I am not complaining
YUM so will Chad lock himself away in
the house and refused to leave our
Jordan and Luke the frontrunners let me
know what you think on Twitter I'll
leave you with this